thomas waren knallt es ausgerechnet
immer wieder in leipzig in connewitz mit
der linksradikalen szene sondern muss
man vielleicht vorher mal einordnen das
connewitz ja nicht dass autonomen
viertel ist als dass es immer
dargestellt wird kommt es ist ein
lebendiger stadtteil mit 20.000 leuten
unter diesen 20.000 leuten leben so
schätzt dass der verfassungsschutz etwa
250 gewaltbereite linksradikale und die
machen in dieser stadt seit jahren
stimmung
sie sind dort im grunde seit dem
wendejahr 1990 91
man muss um das zu verstehen was da
passiert tatsächlich in diese wilde
wende zwar zurückgehen und mal gucken
wie leipzig eigentlich 1990 91 aus dass
leipzig war wie überall im osten eine
stadt in der es große spannung zwischen
linken und rechten zwischen neonazis
gehabt neonazis haben auf den straßen
rekrutiert szenen wie in hoyerswerda wie
in rostock lichtenhagen als in leipzig
nicht gegeben auch weil und das ist auch
ein teil der wahrheit weil es dort eine
kampfbereite autonome szene gab die im
grunde der polizei die arbeit abgenommen
hat die behörden haben das dann in
leipzig geduldet zwei jahre lang bis es
aber auch besetzte haus geduldet bis es
zu einem zwischenfall kam wo polizisten
hausbesetzer dabei erwischt haben die
scheiben eingeschmissen haben dann
lösten sich im handgemenge ein schuss
und von dem tag im november 2 1992
kippte die stimmung
und da gab es neben dem feindbild der
erreichten auch das feindbild des
rechtsstaats und seitdem gibt es in
leipzig connewitz nach wie vor in jeder
ist silvesternacht randale es gibt
eigentlich anlassunabhängige randale im
grunde jeder anlass recht um dort auf
die straße zu gehen
polizisten zu jagen gewalt anzuwenden ob
das die indie media demo war anfang des
jahres die wir erlebt haben
mit verheerenden ausschreitungen oder
jetzt die ausschreitung nach einem nach
der räumung eines besetzten hauses wie
wird jetzt versucht das in den griff zu
bekommen von der polizei und auch von
der politik
man muss sagen die polizei hat viele
jahre lang sehr defensiv
agiert in dem fall die politik hat sich
auch das ist ein teil der wahrheit auch
mit dieser szene engagiert weil diese
szene eben auch dafür gesorgt hat dass
sobald rechtsradikale tendenzen aufkam
war wir an die fahrzeug ständer in
leipzig anders als in dresden zum
beispiel hat der der leipziger peggy da
ein ableger in leipzig auch deshalb sei
auch deshalb nicht nur deshalb keine
chance gehabt weil es dort so bald
richtung marschierten
auch ein massiven widerstand aus der
autonomen szene kam
das hat die stadt natürlich gefördert
und das hat dafür hat sich die stadt
auch rangiert man muss sagen die die
stadt bewilligt auch geld in nicht
unerheblicher höhe um sogenannte
soziokulturelle zentren zu fördern die
vom verfassungsschutz ganz klar als als
als herd und sammelbecken der autonomen
szene gewertet werden
ob sich da jetzt was ändert das können
wir nur hoffen ist jetzt endlich werden
stimmen laut der leipziger
oberbürgermeister spricht von
straßenterror vom linken terror seit ein
paar monaten in der stadt und wir wollen
hoffen dass da jetzt ein bisschen
frieden einkehrt mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dir das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren